good morning everyone and welcome to
bioinformatics
for precision medicine this program will
highlight biomedical applications of big
data bioinformatics in the context of
major diseases like cancer
and chronic infection for those joining
us for the first time
my name is elia brodsky i am the
co-founder and ceo of pine biotech
our vision is to enhance human health
and well-being by enabling biological
research and discovery with relevant
data
solutions and support our mission is to
simplify bioinformatics and advance
research
through our modular and intuitive
multi-omics analysis platform
powered by human experience and
artificial intelligence
we offer training research support and
big data analytics tools
designed for research and biomedical
discovery our mission
is to continue to support cutting-edge
research and help solve
big data challenges by developing
innovative solutions that are easy to
use
and provide training to use them
effectively and arrive at sound and
reproducible results
i am honored to have been working in
pine biotech with many others
many of our team members have much more
experience in this area than i
including pine biotech co-founders dr
alfred tauber who comes from a medical
background with expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
inflammation
he has a long-standing recognition for
his generous support
of many international projects and
research activities one of these
projects
is the establishment of the tower
bioinformatics research center at
university of haifa
dr lean at brodsky is the director of
the tower bioinformatics research center
and is an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics
he has numerous publications on
bioinformatics and over the course of
his career has developed multiple novel
algorithmic approaches for biomedical
data analysis
these have been widely used in basic and
translational research in biotechnology
pharmaceutical r d agriculture and
biomedical research
what we will discuss today is also the
result of hard work by some of the
people mentioned here on the left
julia pinoff who is an expert
bioinformatician and has helped
prepare many of the materials that we
will use in this course
avi titivski who is a computer scientist
and leads the development of the t-biome
for platform that we will utilize mohit
mazumdar who is in charge of business
development for pine biotech
internationally
joshua mckendall who maintains the
educational web portal we will leverage
and beeps biswas our online community
manager and support specialist
why i'm sure many of you had already had
the chance to interact with
the program is designed to highlight the
role of
big data bio and camo informatics
these are shaping modern biomedical
innovation where molecular data is used
for precision diagnostics
big data integration and machine
learning are transforming
personalization of treatment selection
and innovative algorithms that allow for
unprecedented capabilities
with drug discovery design of large
molecules
and drug repurposing and repositioning
molecular data is routinely used in
medicine for patient stratification and
diagnosis of diseases like
breast cancer because many patients have
been diagnosed using these panels in
long-term clinical trials
clinicians can assess the risk of cancer
recurrence and survival
based on information that they provide
in this chart
you can see a mire kaplan curve of
survival
and recurrence based on two clinical
gene panels for breast cancer
bam 50 and oncotype dx
these panels separate patients into
three groups
high medium and low risk
based on these assessments a treatment
can be selected
traditional treatments for cancer are
surgery radiotherapy
and chemotherapy each one of these
treatments can have
multiple harmful side effects and is
known to be effective
in only specific situations for example
tumors are typically irradiated before
surgery
or if they are considered to be somewhat
benign
chemotherapy targets cell proliferation
and often affects many other cells in
the body
so not just the tumor causing severe
discomfort to patients and in some cases
leading to complicated and even
recurrence or emergence of new cancers
however since the 1990s
a new type of treatment started emerging
in clinical use called targeted
cancer therapy one such therapy
is called herceptin or trastuzumab
this is a monoclonal antibody that
blocks the her2 receptor preventing it
from receiving
the growth factor and slowing cell
growth
since then immunotherapy has transformed
cancer care
many of such precision drugs are the
result of biomedical research
studies of the tumor and its
microenvironment
mapping the changes that characterize
tumors
and the novel understanding of the
biological pathways
inside tumor cells as well as signaling
pathways between
tumors and their microenvironment have
led to multiple
innovative interventions blocking
suppressing
and enabling existing mechanisms of
action
to mitigate the effects of uncontrolled
proliferation and metastasis
obdivo also called nivolumab
is one such example this drug was
approved for medical use in the united
states in 2014
it is on the world health organization's
list of essential medicines
the safest and most effective medicines
needed in a health system
op devo is a medication used to treat a
number of types of cancer including
melanoma
lung cancer renal cell carcinoma
hodgkin lymphoma head and neck cancer
colon cancer
and liver cancer but these benefits
require multiple biomarkers to guide
treatment selection
and evaluate their effectiveness placing
data analysis
at the center of such precision
treatments
for example nivolumab is used as a
first-line treatment for
inoperable or metastatic melanoma in
combination with another drug called
ipilimumab another monoclonal antibody
if the cancer does not have a mutation
in the b
raf gene it is also used as a second
lion treatment
for inoperable or metastatic melanoma
following treatment of
epileum and if the cancer has a breast
mutation
a breath inhibitor it is also used to
treat
metastatic squamous non-small cell lung
cancer
with progression in or after
platinum-based drugs and for treatment
of small
cell lung cancer it is also used as a
second line treatment for renal cell
carcinoma
after anti-angiogenic treatment has
failed
so you can see how these treatments
bringing novel precision
really require constant use of
biomarkers
and very detailed understanding of
molecular processes
that happen at the subcellular level
that's why data its analysis and
integration
is at the center of modern precision
medicine
researchers biologists doctors and
clinical lab
technicians are trained to understand
and utilize
complicated molecular clinical and other
high-throughput research data
to diagnose disease as well as develop
use and evaluate treatment efficacy
growth in data generation specifically
when it comes to high throughput
sequencing of cancer genomes and
transcriptomes
has produced a big data problem that
precludes
many cancer biologists and oncologists
from gleaning knowledge from these data
regarding the nature of malignant
processes
as well as the understanding of the
relationships between tumor genomic
profiles
and treatment response in this
program we will focus on such data
learning about the various types of
omics data
including data that describes
intracellular and intercellular
processes associated with disease
we will also look at the role of
pathogens and microorganisms in our
bodies
and the environment we live in to
understand risks they pose
to cause acute infectious disease and
chronic risks
that destabilize the immune system and
lead to cancer associated factors
and we will look at data sets that allow
us to study the relationship between
clinical
and phenotypic data and understand the
molecular biology characterized by
omics data what is often
underappreciated in programs designed
around cancer
is the increasing role of viruses that
we now understand
who pose a tremendous risk for cancer to
develop
and complicate treatment the
epstein-barr
virus formerly called human gamma herpes
virus 4 is one of such viruses one of
the most common viruses in human
it is best known as the cause of
infectious
mononucleosis or mono it is also
associated with various non-malignant
pre-malignant and malignant
epstein-barr virus-associated lymphomas
the virus the virus is also associated
with the childhood disorders
of alice in wonderland syndrome and
acute cerebral
ataxia and based on some evidence higher
risk of developing certain autoimmune
diseases such as lupus
rheumatoid arthritis and multiple
sclerosis
sclerosis about 200
000 cancer cases per year are thought to
be attributable
to ebv another prevalent dna virus
is human papilloma virus from the
papilloma verde family approximately
five percent of all new cancers
diagnosed in 2002
were attributable to hpv another such
pathogen
is hepatitis b and c the most
common risk factor for liver cancer
about 60 of liver cancer diagnoses
are due to causes of chronic and
hepatitis b
leading to over 7